kissing clicking sputtering these are
just some of the odd sounds that people
around the world actually use to speak
come hear these unusual phonemes try
them out yourself and find out which one
of them is something you say everyday in
English weird sounds in world languages
not my normal fare but I'm feeling
something light before we get into more
linguistic tales let's go a row of
languages all lined up in Africa have a
sound written GABA GB so when you run
across this name of a dance from the
Cote d'Ivoire you might be tempted to go
French on it and call it Gabby Gabby but
notice that Thai on the top it's one
single sound to make it bring your
tongue up to the soft palate and make a
gun but also close and release your lips
during that go for a combo Guba sound
but make me there's a voiceless form too
hey in the world atlas of language
structures with its cross language data
on common and uncommon sounds these are
rare enough that they're only an 8% of
the languages sampled can you putter
your lips like if you're cold oh that's
a bilabial trill phonetically speaking
don't pat yourself on the back for it
though a number of languages use poo and
blue sounds but in the far reaches of
Brazil deep in the Amazon live the
piraha a people whose language has
stirred up some linguistic controversy
one of its unusual features is a
bilabial trilled affricate to make it
they hold their tongue in position for a
tea sound against the thief then release
it with that sputtering lip trill oh I
see where the sound is rare try this
next type of sound might be more
familiar to some of you out there for in
joules the pharynx is straight in the
back of your mouth where the nasal
cavity connects to the throat connects
to the voice box if you bring the bass
the root of the tongue way back the
restricted airflow makes this sound
am i breathing you're here this isn't
creepy at all voice that sound and it's
ha do you know which major world
language has sounds close to both of
these and expects you to tell them apart
from nearby glottal huh and velar huh
it's Arabic and other afro-asiatic
languages in all Ferengi only 4% of the
languages in that world sample a Spanish
island in the Canaries off the coast of
Africa La Gomera makes some intriguing
noises unlike the previous examples
their oddity isn't a sound it's actually
a whole way of speaking using whistles
it's called LC blow the whistle by
locals who use high or low frequency
combined with either flows or breaks to
communicate both vowels and consonants
[Music]
the west-african but that lippy trill in
Brazil for angels in Semitic so far our
rares are clustered in hot zones but
this next rarity is found all around the
planet
prepare your tongue for dental
fricatives you won't really need much
practice though because English has them
hmm
putting the tongue up against the teeth
in pushing a stream of air flow around
it this way is only done in somewhat
over 7% of that world language sample
all right English you know how French is
infamous for its nasal sounds oh ho ho
French got them when a nosy sound spread
one vowel over that happens but nasal
spreading doesn't have to stop there
spread away through vowels through
consonants until whole stretches of
sounds become downright infected with
the nasal like in the FBI language of
columbia where cecil comes out as seal
soon lots of odd consonants so far but I
found some fun valves along a river in
Oaxaca Mexico in a town where they speak
um us a tech language for everyone
normal value give them they have three
for you
normal ah which linguists call modal
voice but also breathy voice ah and
creaky voice ah they even do this with
nasals
ah ah add to this that they also have
tones all these consonants you've never
tried to tell apart and even their own
whistle speech and you've got yourself a
mouthful one last one before we go
time for the oddest speech sounds out
there making their home in the southwest
of Africa are the Kois on languages this
isn't a single family even though mass
comparison struck again it's a cluster
of families renowned for possessing
entire sets of sounds called clicks this
is a kiss I mean a bilabial click kind
of even looks like a kiss to make it
speaker's close their tongue against the
back of the mouth and also close both
lips but don't purse them - closures
then using the tongue they suck a pocket
of air into that enclosed area finally
they let go of the lips and out pops up
trapping air between two closures and
then releasing the front closure can be
applied to your teeth the side of your
mouth the roof of your mouth so much
clicking click languages accounted for
just 1.8 percent of that world language
sample well see our world's languages
are full of all kinds of meaningful
strange sounds maybe we'll take a
linguistic trip to one of these hotspots
and investigate further until then stick
around and subscribe for language
[Music]
you